Now let us look at
set-associative caches.
We say that a cache is
N-way set-associative when
a particular block can be in one of
N possible lines where it can go.
So the overall cache now is
divided into regions called sets.
In this case we have four sets.
A given block can go to one of its sets.
So pretty much we use some bits of
the block's address to tell us which set
does it need to go in.
Within a set there could be a number
of lines that can contain a block.
In this case we have a 2-way
set-associative cache because there
are two lines in a set, so a given block
could be in either of the two lines.
Note that different blocks might go to
different sets, but a particular block
will map to one set and then it has
a choice between the two lines there.
In this particular cache, we have
eight lines, four sets, and two ways.
Note that N is 2 here.
So we say that the cache
is 2-way set-associative,
not when it has two sets, but
when there is two blocks in each set.